we are asked to find these three
different limits I encourage you like
always pause this video and try to do it
yourself before we do it together so
when you do this first one you might
just try to find the limit as X
approaches negative two of f of X and
then the limit as X approaches negative
two of G of X and then add those two
limits together but you will quickly
find a problem because when you find the
limit as X approaches negative two of f
of X it looks as we are approaching
negative two from the left it looks like
we're approaching one as we approach x
equals negative two from the right it
looks like we're approaching three so it
looks like the limit as X approaches
negative 2 of f of X doesn't exist and
the same thing is true of G of X if we
approach from the left it looks like
we're approaching three which approach
from the right it looks like we're
approaching one but turns out that this
limit can still exist as long as the
limit as X approaches negative 2 from
the left of the somme f of X plus G of X
exists and is equal to the limit as X
approaches negative 2 from the right of
the sum f of X plus G of X so what are
these things well as we approach
negative 2 from the left f of X is
approaching looks like 1 and G of X is
approaching 3 so it looks like we're
approaching 1 & 3 so it looks like this
is approaching the sum is going to
approach 4 and if we're coming from the
right f of X looks like it's approaching
3 and G of X looks like it is
approaching 1 and so once again this is
equal to 4 and since the left and right
handed limits are approaching the same
thing we would say that this limit
exists and it is equal to 4 now let's do
this next example as X approaches 1 well
we'll do the exact same exercise and
once again if you look at the individual
limits for f of X from the left and the
right as we approach 1 this limit
doesn't exist but the limit as X
approaches 1 of the sum might exist so
let's try that out so the limit as X
approaches 1 from the left hand side of
f of X plus G of X what is that going to
be equal to as we approach so f of X as
we approach 1 from the left
it looks like this is going approaching
- I'm just doing this for shorthand and
G of X as we approach one from the left
it looks like it is approaching zero so
this will be approaching two plus zero
which is two and then the limit as X
approaches 1 from the right hand side of
f of X plus G of X is going to be equal
to well for f of X as we're approaching
one from the right hand side looks like
it's approaching a negative one and for
G of X as we're approaching one from the
right hand side looks like we're
approaching a zero again and so here it
looks like we're approaching negative
one so the left and right hand limits
aren't approaching the same value so
this one does not exist and then last
but not least X approaches 1 of f of X
times G of X so we'll do the same drill
limit as X approaches 1 from the left
hand side of f of X times G of X well
here and we could even use the values
here we see we was approaching 1 from
the left we are approaching 2 so this is
2 and when we're approaching 1 from the
left here we're approaching 0 and so
this is going to be 2 times we're going
to be approaching 2 times 0 which is 0
and then we were approached from the
right X approaches 1 from the right of f
of X times G of X well we already saw
when we're approaching 1 from the right
of f of X we are approaching negative 1
but G of X approaching 1 from the right
is still approaching 0 so this is going
to be 0 again so this limit exists we
get the same limit when we approach from
the left and the right it is equal to 0
so these are pretty interesting examples
because sometimes when you think that
the component limits don't exist that
that means that the sum or the product
might not exist but this shows at least
two examples where that is not the case